we can't think of a more interesting and
exciting time to launch this course yes
there are challenges that you and your
peers will face because my baby boom
generation didn't do a great job of
keeping our policies and practices up to
date with the changing economy and the
changing workforce but at the same time
we're in an extremely interesting era of
innovation around the world were seeing
new organizations getting formed using
crowdsourcing and other modern
techniques organizations we couldn't
even have imagined several years ago
there are new worker advocacy
organizations coming along that will
help empower you to find your way in the
labor market there are new apps that
allow you to navigate this labor market
and to figure out where the good jobs
are and distinguish between good and bad
employers and then there are courses
like this exploding all around our
universities here in the United States
and in other countries we rise and fall
on the strength of our middle class
these online courses allow you to
getting access to some of the world's
leading experts in your particular field
the role of the corporation in the US
has changed quite a bit so it's time to
really bring all of this together and
see if we can't help really shape the
future of work we're going to introduce
you to lots of companies that are
breaking new ground in every industry we
can find great companies that are doing
well financially serving their customers
well focused on a mission that is really
important for society and providing good
jobs one of the things we want to do is
to highlight those and to learn more
about your own experiences with
companies and organizations like this
and so as we go along we're gonna learn
from your experiences and you're going
to meet a whole set of peers who have
good jobs and maybe not such good jobs
some mentors who are ready to work with
you to provide advice and all of that
will be a learning process together
and let me say a word about another
piece of this course that I'm especially
excited about in every week we're gonna
have something called the personal
development corner this is designed to
provide you with a path forward so that
you can be empowered to take control of
your own career
so there'll be readings videos and
exercises and assignments that allow you
to understand what are some of your
capabilities what are some of your
interests what jobs might fit well with
your background and where you would like
to go with your own career and how will
you develop your own personal career
plan to make sure that you are ready to
take advantage of the opportunities that
are out there so let's start exploring
this evolving and interesting world of
work let's do it with our eyes open
let's understand and learn from our
history about what worked in the past
what's broken what needs to be fixed and
why and then let's see if together we
can't shape the future of work for your
generation
so let's get started
you